was goody everyone I thought it would be
whiter out here
I thought I had a better lighting it's
kind of dark
oh it's fine
I'm shooting in my backyard like why is
this not great yeah and I only still see
your
uh your face
you don't see your face
I don't see my face no
well if you go to um
live
your face should be there
um
because Emily just said you both look
great
hey I'll take it oh yeah so we're both
live streaming yeah we're both we're
both on if you see in the Facebook group
or
um the whatchamacallit
uh YouTube channel
oh nice
yes okay we're on both fam
so hopefully yeah this is
laughs
this is this
welcome back everyone
you wanted a weekly live stream
so here you go
I think last week we wore sunglasses and
I was recovering
from uh drinking brain
and then this week I was just like
whatever we're outside let's switch it
up my wife is sick so I was just doing
this outside
oh nice
yeah that's on me I was sick
and then got her sick it's the worst
it's the worst yeah
that's how it happens exactly so it's
all a big pity party over here how's it
going over there
oh
you know kids running around actually
they all went to go play at like the
playground so it's actually kind of
quiet which is kind of nice
stoppage on the ceiling which is
refreshing every once in a while
no one taking up your uh your bandwidth
on the router no fortnite poaching going
on here
absolutely
fortnite in my mind craft
yeah Minecraft's bumping
dude
uh Mr Beast and his Minecraft channels
are just killing it dude killing it
good for him oh and we're killing it too
though we got people hanging we got
people commenting
as we're even into this this is
n't it John Wall dragon and Imlay
I crack myself up Carol keto Carol
mookie G
[Music]
we appreciate y'all for showing up every
week despite us not promoting it that
just means the world to us
facts
b or facts
so what we what we started doing here
was somewhat of a a weekly q a
and I posted in um a poll in our
Facebook group getting questions if
anyone watching has questions
um
but what question I have
is
um for Mr Yoshi so I don't know if
anyone has subscribed to the
World Series of Comedy email
but I opened up their Atlanta one
and Mr Yoshi so was front and center his
face was the
The Talk of the Town the the bell of the
ball if you will hey hey we we trying we
trying to get it
pull it up for the people that watch on
our YouTube channel which if you're guys
are listening to the podcast
then you're missing out on the live
stream
Tuesday on our YouTube channel and in
our Facebook group
we are doing a live q a so come on and
hang out with us next Tuesday I know
you're listening on the podcast now but
you never know what's gonna happen
you never know so yeah
so I just did the uh did the contest in
San Diego at a very cool Club two cool
clubs out there I didn't do the Friday
show but there's two clubs that we did
it at San Diego mic drop which is cool
spot in San Diego
um and then the other one is the stand
up I want to say it's just called uh
God why am I forgetting the name
it's in Bellflower
I know it sounds weird but it might just
be like stand-up comedy club like it's
such a
generic like name that's the name of it
yeah hilarious I'm I I'm I don't want to
do any of the service because they were
super good people the stand-up comedy
club that's the name of it I was like
it's I think it's
something different but no it is just
straight up the stand-up comedy club
well all right then
yeah easy enough
easy enough yeah what's interesting
about the the mic drop is the guy that
won while you were out there in
California uh Matt Dern deck
yeah yeah
we work together pre-pandemic at uh the
drop which was in uh which is in Indiana
it's a comedy club called the drop we
work together out there
yeah so it's cool to see things come
full circle
for sure how was that show
oh it was nice I think they moved
locations I think we're in like a bigger
place now as well but it was a lot of
fun and while we're on the topic of
World Series of Comedy
I actually met the booker of the drop
at a World Series of Comedy event
so yeah World Series of Comedy
yeah absolutely I know we both are done
a lot with them so how was your trip out
there did you see any hot Brethren did
tell us tell us because these kids are
listening like oh my gosh Festival he
flew across the country for a Comedy
Festival like what give us the D yeah I
mean honestly it was good
um I went there stayed with a comedy
friend of mine
um who I met at uh World Series last
year
um so we became good friends and then he
came out here actually for Western
Comedy Festival his name was
um Jim Gallagher very funny and then uh
when I got there the show was really
really good I didn't get to see the
first night so I didn't get there till
like Thursday so I actually drove into I
was I flew into LAX and then drove to
San Diego and then the first night of
the show you know it's just two separate
lineups uh nine people a piece this was
the second round
and I think the biggest thing for me was
truly just to like have a mindset of
having fun I know uh you and I talked
just earlier about how sometimes some of
these contests get a little I get a
little in my head about them and kind of
myself out but I think what I focus on
having fun
the results don't matter and I'm just
happy with exactly what I did so that's
kind of really how it was
um I did my show and I did my set very
very happy with it
um probably going to use it as a sort of
a it's a seven minute so I'm gonna use
that for future Clips because I was
super happy with it and it's mostly
because I had a great time on stage and
like keeping that Focus was more
important than anything else
I didn't move on but I was super excited
about what I did on stage I met hot
breath Aaron Sampson we were on the same
show
um he did awesome
um we talked a little bit afterwards uh
and we just had good discussion just all
around
um and then a lot of the people I've
seen before haven't met Matt before but
I've heard his name
um in other places but you know it was
just good to just like see he's got a
very different comedy style Matt does
but also
um
everybody else was a little different as
well so it's just good to see kind of
like different styles of Comedy there's
definitely like a style of New York
comedian there's definitely a style of
like La comic as well yeah
but like just you know at the end of the
day it's about making people laugh so uh
I was super happy with it and I would
say you know not to flex but as soon as
I got on stage off stage
um I exchanged cards with the uh one of
the managers there and basically she was
just like hey if you're ever in town hit
me up so for me that's like that's a win
that's exactly what I wanted yeah it's
just somebody to see it and be like oh
you could really rock our stage that's
all that truly mattered to me so for me
that's a win even though I didn't move
on just having that connection now is
like golden for me
yeah I feel like that's what World
Series is best for is like networking
with other comics
and also networking like they they're
like big intentions like connecting
comedians with Bookers you know like
that's that's what they're all about
so
um anytime I've done something World
Series I've always gotten booked from it
so
it's definitely valuable
yeah yeah no so it was good man I mean
no complaints and then the shows were
good
um and yeah
um I'm doing another one in Louisville
Kentucky uh about two weeks and then the
Atlanta one and I think I'm doing
Louisville and then I'm gonna do uh the
one in Florida
at uh Sarasota and then I'm gonna do the
Atlanta one and those might be it for me
noise
yeah and basically how theirs works if
people are wondering each City like each
city is like a satellite and then is it
the winners of those go to the finals in
Vegas
so the top uh three of any of the
satellites
um automatically go into Vegas and then
if you don't make the top three but
you've got enough points throughout all
the satellites you also get an invite
for the top 101 basically gotcha very
cool
and this actually ties in
um to a question we had in our Facebook
group where Danny Tran actually asked
how many years
in comedy before you started submitting
to festivals
I was probably like
two and a half three years in but I I
would say like don't use the years as a
gauge I I would just say if you feel
like you've got a comfortable
10 minutes so here's the thing about the
all right let me pull back the World
Series is Feature work you're basically
guaranteed Feature work and Feature work
is anywhere between 20 to 35 minutes
I would not submit unless you've got 35
40 minutes of solid material that you
believe you're comfortable with mainly
because when you're doing the comedy and
you go on to all the stages the last
final three of every
um satellite is basically a 25 minute
set so you gotta push out a 25 minute
set so if you move forward you got to be
able to do 25
um at the satellite so I would say be
comfortable at a
40 45 that way you're 25 that is like
straight up
you know a material you can sort of hit
that for that 25 minutes that's sort of
how I approached it so I
when I did it I was year three year
four-ish when I did my first one
um actually I don't think I did it till
year four
uh
in terms of at least for the World
Series I didn't do two year four but
I've submitted to other festivals
because the other festivals they don't
need 25 minutes you know I think they
only really want you to have like 10
maybe 15 minutes because you're really
only doing uh that much time at their
Festival so just look at what length of
time that they want and then yeah I
would just start submitting if you're
comfortable with your material for the
amount of material that they want to
they want to sort of highlight at their
show
yeah that's a good point and for people
that just jumped in the live stream I
see Andrew in here and Heather
and Jerry and Jess me I see some people
posting questions and Bob uh the topic
we're talking about Danny Tran had asked
when we started swinging to festivals
and for me
I don't even remember and honestly I
don't really submit to that many
festivals at all and I feel like every
time I see our comedy buddy Wellington
he's like you're doing the vessels man
you'd be good to come on here because
he's he's great at that at those um yeah
I don't know I really just don't I
haven't really submitted to
many if any
to be honest I've done stuff with World
Series
I did some with red clay here in Atlanta
uh one year I did like a podcast thing
with them and then never again but
that's fine you know I'm not bitter
I'm not bitter at all
not at all
I just feel bad for the P I just feel
bad you know for the people that almost
but then you know didn't type A vibe I
just I mean you know yesterday's price
is not today's price is basically
that's really what it boils down to but
I'm not bitter and I'm grateful and uh
so yeah
so those are really the only Festival
but I know friends and I know Yoshi's
very active in festivals as well and a
little more extroverted it is like a
great opportunity to network
thanks to get quality stage time if it's
a quality Festival there's so many
festivals out there
that if you have a question about one if
you posted on our Facebook group you'd
probably be able to get some feedback on
is this worth submitting to what's this
Festival like and kind of get a dialogue
going because each one is totally
different
um yeah submission process is different
acceptance rate is different so each
one's different so
I haven't really done that much with
festivals but I know people who haven't
gotten a lot out of them
so I will say that
yeah I mean I would say it's one of
those things that uh mookie just
mentioned be prepared to get rejected a
lot which is a great Point I've
submitted to a lot of festivals get
rejected a lot but it's not like the
rejections get you closer to the like
it's those are the no's that get you
closer to the yeses
the the stuff that I was submitting the
first time
probably wasn't great if I look back on
it now it probably was not like high
material and now that I'm submitting I'm
like oh this is fire stuff that I think
we'll get in but still it could still be
trash to them I mean you never know what
the festival goers you never know who's
sort of booking or whatever but you know
you hope that over time you learn sort
of what they're looking for
um who's the kid that you interviewed
um Andrew Frank uh he was on the
Hamilton series
yeah and Andrew Frank is like a festival
God that dude did social festivals and
like lived off of festivals and lived
off of like truly like mastering the art
form of the festival and that also
parlayed him into more and more gigs so
he just figured out oh I I don't want to
say he figured out completely but he
knew kind of like
I don't want to say the formula but what
got the festival uh Bookers like
it's like he was like oh this is what
they like I can do this I can do this
kind of material for them yeah and so
I've interviewed Andrew and speaking of
festivals I have interviewed uh Andrew
George who runs the Laughing Skull
Festival he gave a lot of good Insight
on Festival submissions and just a point
of view of a club Booker in general and
I've interviewed uh both co-founders of
World Series of Comedy Joe and Jason
both amazing dudes I've interviewed them
a few times
wants to go back and listen to more
yeah festivals aren't are they're not an
absolute thing but they do definitely
get you exposure
um even if you're not don't get into a
festival you could still go to a
festival
there's a lot of networking that can be
done I mean we talk about this a lot of
the gigs that you're gonna get do not
come from Bookers that come from other
comedians who truly are like oh I've
messed with you I think you're funny
you'd be great for my show that I'm
running in this town so just know that
festivals also get you to connect on all
those other cities that you might want
to visit and you might want to do a show
at
yes and this comes with a disclaimer
that
this does not guarantee you will submit
get into a festival and then meet your
person that changes your life
very well may submit to 50 get accepted
to two of them go and get nothing out of
either Beyond just stage time so I want
to put that disclaimer out there as well
that we're not guaranteeing anything
we've learned that but just remember
those festivals I would say always you
know this is just my little set of rules
go to a festival that has Bookers
outside of the festival goers where they
are bringing Bookers into the city
Laughing Skull brings Bookers from JFL
they bring Bookers from South by South
South and we found like they're bringing
people in to watch the talent same thing
with Big Pine same thing with I mean
World Series like a lot of the festivals
I would say may for me my number one
rule is who's going to be there to at
least give me some level of exposure to
say oh I liked what you did or yeah that
wasn't great because the other thing is
those Bookers actually do talk to you
and you can add an app for feedback
they're not all going to give you
feedback but I would say 90 of them are
willing to be like oh you know something
it was a little premature they'll give
you notes on what they liked versus what
they didn't like and yeah that for me
felt like super important
um overall like oh okay this is where
you think I am and then the other thing
is Bookers also like to see progress
they like to say oh I've seen you before
now I've seen you like escalate we'd
love to have you for the festival
yeah that's a good point you got me
thinking we need to start setting up
some affiliate links with these
festivals we gotta go
yeah where the bread at Shawty
where the bag at fam
anyway
so I had to go to white boy Joel for a
second
I did I did a fundraiser this weekend
how was that
I was the only white boy in the lineup
that's you know that's my that's my
that's my Lane right there you know
that's my safe spot that's my sweet spot
so I was in the zone I was in the pocket
in there and I told myself before the
show
that I'm not going to do race stuff I
was like I'm I'm evolving I'm
metamorphosizing this this
you're phoenixing I'm phoenixing
um the the caterpillar to butterfly I'm
metamorphosis and
it something came up
that made me bring up race and then I
kind of went on this riff about how I'm
trying to not do Rey's stuff and that
was getting laughs
so I think I got new material out of it
but then I just leaned into the race
stuff and the laughter went from like
eight to ten
and then I and I went and I was like see
see you got boxing me in here see how
can I compete with those laughs it was
all funny
um yeah we'll hear about grape nuts real
quick yeah I did I did I did my zoom
therapy bit and it got like pretty much
crickets I did all this race stuff and
then a zoom therapy bit and they're like
what
it's so funny but it was a lot yeah it
was a lot of fun and I danced I did the
gritty and the floss
yes it was chucked and jived but it was
really good
it was a lot of fun I don't know why I I
can't remember why I brought that up now
my 80d
took me to was it booking it
I don't know you were just talking about
um
we're talking about festivals
yeah you're talking about Festival
you're talking about the affiliate links
and getting the bag
oh so that was like bringing up the bag
at the fundraiser oh the fundraiser made
me think of the bag and I was like I'm
really getting paid for my time
and um
fairly
but it was booked by a hot brother and
it is I think maybe whatever so all
y'all listening y'all y'all booking
stuff holla at us we'll we'll pull up
for sure
okay cool uh oh yeah and Jesse said I'm
producing a show at mic drop on March
30th and that we should come out there
is that San Diego
uh that might jump I think might be in
Phoenix because there's a bike drop in
Phoenix
oh wow oh and Jerry said keto Carol's
killing it in Phoenix because she's all
over all the Flyers which is cool it's
awesome we may be doing our um what are
you doing a country club that day anyway
though I think so yeah March 30th or
31st we are
um so yeah we won't be able to do it
this time but hey definitely
if the price is right
summer tour is what I'm thinking Joel
summer tour yeah yeah
nice little hot breath tour just across
the country
um
what's the little light work just want
to get away from your family that's all
you're trying to do you're like yo let's
go on a road trip forever
he's trying to duck out
laughs
I'm not saying you're lying but I do
spend some time with my family but it'd
just be fun just to like I I just think
like the summer months is easier for me
because then I don't have as much like
kids school
I think we'd have to put a run together
yeah yeah yeah I think so for sure
um oh and I cracked myself up asked the
difference between a festival and a
competition
um world series is a competition and a
festival
um I mean competitions really I don't
even know if there's really like
competitions anymore
in terms of festivals World Series
that's like a competition competition
and I love learning about festivals man
I loved that it was the competition
I used to love that I know laughing
School used to be a good test yeah let's
go used to be a contest and I think like
I mean very much
for
World Series
I don't want to say it's a guarantee but
the clubs pretty much will give you
Feature work if you win that club that's
part of another thing
um if you won the contest if you if not
only if you win the contest but if you
win like their satellite so if you want
to satellite oh yeah you get the you get
uh a feature weekend basically they're
like okay come out because I know
somebody who didn't win the contest but
they want a feature weekend
um at one of the places and then I saw
them that weekend I came in for like a a
guest spot and they're like oh yeah this
is my future weekend with this club that
I won at for that weekend so you know
they honored it and I think it was a
Chattanooga gig or something like that
but yeah it was awesome oh very nice
oh very nice
there's also like
there's a Facebook group as well not a
Facebook group there's like a list of
all the
um
comedy festivals as well I think we
might have shared it in a hot breath a
while back but I think we did too yeah
and then there's also like local
competitions that like people will do
like a one-off where you buy and see if
you win type deal so that's more that's
what I think when I hear like
competition or contest is more of like
a one-off thing sometimes clubs do or
sometimes just yeah someone will put
together where you buy in and then maybe
win
um
yeah I mean I probably said form under
pressure you know and like I mean like
contests are good for that festivals are
good for that like getting out of your
comfort zone and really performing
like in a different environment that
you're not used to you'll be surprised I
mean as you get out of your scenes more
like you'll get into you'll get on a
stage never been on and be like oh like
oh this I feel like I'm starting over
almost like
there's definitely a learning curve to
be able to adapt to new environments
very quickly because early when I was
doing clubs like it would take me
at least a night to like acclimate and
be like get my sea legs on the stage in
front of that crowd it's like it's
there's a learning curve there that uh
festivals and contests can really help
with too
yeah yeah
um there was a question uh John asked
what are your thoughts on riffing on
stuff the comic before you said
um that's a good question I
if there was if there's something
interesting that the comedian said and
I've got a joke for it I definitely will
use it before I go into my set I would
say you gotta get in the habit where
that is always hitting and it's got to
be super short so you're not taken away
from your set because if it doesn't hit
and then now you've got to bring the
audience back it can really like make it
hard for you to get them back so I would
say
practice it but like get good at like
I've always said the shorter it is the
better
like the shorter the like the hit like
it's like set up Punch or just a punch
line or you repeat something
um I wouldn't go into long setup or long
story like I'll see some hosts that say
things like well speaking of uh Dust
Busters uh here's a story about dust
busting yeah and it sucks the energy out
of the room based on the fact that the
guy who just went last like had all this
energy for his closer and then but now
you want to bring up a story so that
would be the only thing I would say keep
it tight and quick in terms of riffing
on something that the comics said before
I know some comedians that's like their
thing they'll riffle up something and go
right into their set
um uh it was a local community that does
that really really well Neil Reddy
masterful
dude like I've never seen him not crush
on saying something right before and
then as soon as it hits he goes right
into a set and it does great but yeah I
think it makes you makes the audience
believe that you are actively listening
as a comic yeah and it can be good
practice in terms of like riffing and
kind of becoming more conversational on
stage you just don't want to become a
crutch
yeah and you don't want to be like
forced if there's just something like at
the tip of your tongue that you're like
oh I gotta say this or want to say this
but don't don't make that your primary
objective of the set is like oh let me
listen to Comic before so I can get my
opener like if it's organic then go for
it but otherwise don't try to just
shoehorn it in
just for the sake and um another thing
is like you mentioned with the host
going long I've seen Comics reference
like the comic says something and then
the host goes up for a couple minutes
and then the next comment goes up and
references the other comic but it was
too much time gone the audience the
audience already forgot what that comic
said or whatever so they tried to play
off of it and it was so I mean use it
you you practice it but don't use it as
a crutch I would say
yeah great point and only I mean I mean
this is going to take time man only say
it if you know it's going to do well if
you're like to say it's gonna be funny
yeah it's gonna be funny if it's like oh
this might be interesting absolutely not
say to yourself first or say to somebody
else that's what I've done I have done
that at a show and I'll ask another
comedian hey do you think this will be
funny if I say this and if they're like
oh that's that's trash I'm like all
right I'm not even gonna do it
yeah just if it's organic and funny
you know give it a test you know I mean
all the riffing and stuff I think
when I initially started practicing
riffing it was in
uh a bar and a strip mall next to a
closed grocery store
on Tuesdays
it was at a bar called spuds where they
sold big baked potatoes that's all they
sold
and um so then there we're in the middle
of a dance floor the disco ball is going
I went every week you know and
um so I started riffing in there by just
like I made fun of the light and then
like went into my material and then I
would like kind of get a little braver I
went made fun of the light and then
maybe the dance floor and then went to
material and then maybe I made fun of
the light the dance floor and the sign
outside and they went in the material
and I kind of started to expand the the
riffing that way because it's all super
incremental
but it uh it is a great way to flex
especially at a show like that those are
good shows to get weird rub walls you
know really get into it but like at a
club or something you don't do that but
an open mic where you're in the middle
of a dance floor and it's mainly Comics
like
that's open field running you know feel
free to get weird with it try things
and take big swings in those rooms
because the stakes are very low
such a good point and a smart way to
think about it I'm getting roasted in
the comments too Carol said I look like
my live stream is sponsored by Bass Pro
Shops
but then on the other end it's a Kuma
set I'm taking a break from commenting
on the PGA tour
so I'm on both ends of the white elite
Spectrum right now
even just how I said Elite it just like
Elite it just like rolled off the tongue
Elite
anyway oh I did say that fundraiser I
was the the diversity Equity inclusion
higher which I thought was pretty fun
[Laughter]
what was funny it's in a it was in a
small town in Georgia
so the crowd was actually mixed so like
so like there was actually like a good
bit of white people and black people
there but the funny part is the whole
lineup the whole fundraiser is put
together by black comedians so these
white people kind of showed up
and I don't know if they knew exactly I
mean the flyer you know it had all black
comedians and it was fine and everyone
laughed had a good time but I would love
to have seen them as like you know they
were playing you know
Gorilla Zoe or um I was trying to think
of his name
what's a gremlin oh uh what's the
rapper's name Kodak Black
Superstars yeah yeah there we go but
yeah yes
anyway but speaking of which I think a
Carol despite roasting me had a question
when to enter competitions
do all we can early in our career even
though we probably won't win or wait
until you think you're good enough to
win and suffer soul-crushing losses
oh so basically do contests before you
think you're ready
or when you think you're ready
I
I would say do him before you think
you're ready because you got to get a
little uncomfortable and once you get
some of those L's I think you'll be very
surprised that they don't start to hurt
as much later on
yeah I will say though
you only get one first impression as
well so I guess maybe it depends on the
festival I'm just saying if you go
to a festival and the booker sees you as
one way
you know I may have be how they see you
forever or at least for several years so
I think early on I avoided festivals
because I didn't feel like I was ready
and then
I didn't feel like they were worthy I
guess no I'm just kidding I'm just
kidding
thank you
all the humility you're a one-hitter
quitter you're like uh I don't think
they really mess with the with the
buyers but she said local Club
competitions yeah I would
say go for it I mean I think
competitions are great to
get out of your comfort zone and really
like it's so great to have
accountability and something to work
towards you know there was a there was a
contest here in Atlanta for a while
run by uh Road comic Derek tenant so I
think he's been on the road and busy
hasn't done it but it was like three
minutes
I think you submit I think it was thirty
dollars but you won several hundred and
it was three minutes but it was like it
was a good exercise of like okay I gotta
condense everything down I gotta hit
with my best three minutes like so I
would do it every time
wants some because
I would just guess anyone was wondering
and
I would still do it every time because
it was a good exercise of like editing
and Performing under pressure and it
forced it held me accountable to write
you know and to get to three minutes
like that's not easy yeah
nice you gotta squeeze out all the air
on those jokes
foreign
if you're proud of if you're proud of
what you're doing
say you know take a swing you know yeah
and one another good thing just a good
practice
uh uh before you start submitting to
festivals start recording your sets
so when you're recording
first of all
uh I'll tell you this do not record and
submit an open mic set
this is just good practice an open mic
set does not put you in the best light
especially if the open mic has nothing
but comedians in it
the Bookers want to see you at a
showcase and they want to see real
people laugh at your jokes uh uh if
you're testing material out that's not
what you want to submit you want to
submit your best version of yourself
your hot five as they call it in the
industry
um so that's just a good practice to
have try not to submit Open Mic material
unless it's like an open mic that's got
a showcase and you're like showcasing
your stuff but if possible do not submit
open mic
shapes because that is also like we said
with going to a competition it's like
your first impression may be that video
so it's a representation of you
and your comedy so yeah definitely yeah
you're booking tape and your submission
tape yeah don't do it on an iPhone
that's vertical from 15 feet away that
your friend is holding while they're
like giggling or whatever and it's
shaking yeah exactly
yeah that's a really good point though
on the submission side yeah the quality
of your submission yeah make it high
quality
high quality yep uh Jerry
had a question along the networking side
was that Yoshi mentioned business cards
is this still a good idea
social media info on there I probably
say the the way that business cards are
going a lot of people and I'll say I do
this too are just basically putting like
their face so this is my business card
right here it's just my favorite thing
and then on the back some contact info
and then a QR code
for them to reach me and the QR code
actually goes to an EPK that I actually
did with the World Series that's got
like my images my tape uh a bio and
things like that so I that worked for me
and I've gotten booked from that
um I would say yeah business cards
definitely especially if you're going to
a festival
um even to connect with other Comics but
yes of course I also get their IG I
follow them on Facebook all the other
stuff but
I think that's the other thing is
there's not a lot of this is gonna sound
like um I don't know what the word is
Aegis or whatever there's not a lot of
young people that own comedy clubs
yeah
you know what I mean so it's a very
still a very kind of old school
um group of owners who still mess with
business cards
yeah and yeah that is a good point I
have business cards a lot of times
people will ask you like after a show
you know do you like like a fan or
something maybe like do you have a card
or whatever
I will say business card is great it's
something to have
I I can't I can't count on one hand how
many times
I've gotten someone's business card and
then like did something with it besides
throw it away you know besides it
sitting around my office for a while and
then for sure I thought I haven't been
like oh let me get your card okay I'm
gonna hit you up and then me actually go
and email them like maybe a handful of
times I've done that what what really
what really does it is you get their
info be like oh here's my business card
and let me go ahead and get your get
your email and I'll follow up with you
because people
I mean eight times out of ten nine times
out of ten they're not gonna follow up
they're not gonna think about it but
when you follow up they're gonna be glad
you did and be like oh yeah that's right
type deal so
business cards a cool professional
kind of um trinket to have but if it's
with someone that you want to like
really like it's like you're talking
business or something you want to keep
in contact with then like get their
email and you initiate the conversation
facts yeah yeah next steps take it next
level
yeah great Point yeah yeah don't wanna
don't wanna be relying on
anyone to remember x y and z
yeah
that's on you baby
yeah this turned into talking about
festivals
it's turned into a whole thing about
talking about festivals but they are
important and you know there aren't a
lot of
a lot of questions and it's kind of an
unknown world
um
but yeah it's knowing which ones to that
are worth submitting to if you don't
know I'd say ask in our Facebook group
and um they'll be able to help you out
but I think on the all most most
festivals are in it for the right reason
and it's good
good place to meet people and possibly
meet boogers
have been snuffed out is the best way to
describe it people just have been like
no don't submit to that Festival yeah
um and like the good ones have stayed I
would say uh so yeah I mean and you know
obviously tons of Club tons of Bookers
and tons of like producers also do
festivals
do your due diligence find somebody
who's been to the festival before
um and you know
see what it's about before you submit
yeah and this one was uh from
Christopher Wooley on our Facebook group
he said I'm always told not to throw a
joke away but how many times would you
try it out on stage and it not work
before throwing it
a way to look at later how long would
you take before looking back at Old
jokes to try and get a fresh perspective
on it
my magic number is three
but that's just me
um did we do this last week we've done
this question before we've been asked
this question before my magic number is
three and I would say it's three and I
don't count it working I don't count an
open mic in terms of it working or not I
count showcases and places that I'm
getting paid to do it as does this joke
work but I've already worked it out at
the open mic if it doesn't hit at a
showcase even if I squeeze it in between
like fire stuff that's what I'd be like
we're gonna shelve this till it's ready
it's it sometimes a joke gotta go back
in the oven you know what I mean and
reheat it
it's not ready to be eaten yet yeah big
facts yeah it's kind of personal
preference on how many times you want to
do it before
putting it to the side I wouldn't say
throw away anything I'd say yeah you
just kind of shelf it to come back to it
later you can come back to it the next
week the next month the next year the
next decade like it's kind of it's kind
of an organic thing based on your own
personal Judgment of if you believe in
the joke
then you know keep keep hammering but at
a certain point the audience doesn't lie
and if you've been doing it for six
months and it's never worked it may just
be time to shelf it and come back to it
and there's no
like even like Christopher saying that
reminds me of like oh yeah I'm writing
new stuff I should probably revisit
old stuff I wrote and just see what's
there because like early on I just I
have like notebooks of stuff that I've
probably that I probably wrote in and
then just never looked at again
so that could be a that could be a good
resource
um to find new material that Christopher
just tapped me into there so
interesting because I know people will
do that
um I've never really Revisited my stuff
I just kind of kept moving moving and
developing stuff that
just worked in the chaos yeah
but yeah it's kind of personal
preference there Christopher but when
you come back to it with fresh eyes
you'll probably find fresh jokes for it
so put it to the side
oh and this one is
this one is uh this one gets personal
here Jr asked how do you tell your
parents you quit your high paying job to
pursue a career in comedy
I wonder if Jr actually did this
yeah
or is he thinking about it
yeah because he said how do you tell
your parents as if he or you did
I wonder if you did I hope he's still
watching I know he commented in a live
stream
yeah
bruh I don't know on that I mean you're
you're a parent Yoshi so like from a
parent's point of view how would you
want to hear something like that but
you've been you're you're married and
you also like you know like left your
job to pursue comedy so
so I I
this is one of those things that I think
um that it's definitely personal
preference but I would say you should
not quit
your
any job to pursue comedy unless comedy
is just busy like where you're so busy
at comedy that it's dipping into your
time to where you can't focus on the
other thing that's kind of what I would
say is the time to quit a high paying
gig to pursue comedy but just remember
like you know most comedians are working
on weekends maybe Thursday Friday
Saturday Sunday and if you're getting
booked like that where your weekends are
just busy as hell
then yeah maybe it is time to pursue
comedy on a regular basis
on the other side of that I'm not
getting booked and I still left uh my
gig but I left my gig mostly because
I've you know over the years I've built
a nest egg where I can do that and I'm
okay sort of taking that risk
um also I've got a supportive wife at
the house that's like was willing to be
like yeah sure go ahead and do this and
you know we'll see what happens I don't
have like a timeline of when I might
need to Reign it in but you know we'll
see uh so this is just one of those
situations where I think it's definitely
personal preference but I would say
you quitting just make sure like I don't
know how to best say this as a parent
it would be that
don't
pursue life
and make sure that your life is good
before you go ahead and pursue a career
in comedy um so you're doing stuff
by which you're still like
livable
then go do that you know I know
comedians that are have lived in their
car well you can do that and there's
nothing wrong with that we know plenty
of comics AJ Wilkerson lived in his car
um uh dude Frank the guy who were like
he's the king of the festivals he yeah I
don't know if he still is but when I
interviewed him he was living in his car
yeah but he's not anymore but he was but
yeah so like it was for sure right so
sometimes what full-time comedy looks
like is like you're literally living in
your car yeah
and you're going to gigs and doing
things like that right
um so I would say if your lifestyle can
support it then by all means go ahead
and pursue Comedy full time uh but
there's no guarantee because you know
you're at the becking call of Bookers
you're at the beck and call of other
people sort of choosing you for these
gigs the other way to think about it is
that now if you've got like you know uh
the king of Atlanta comedy who we call
Joe Pettis
he left his gig and he was producing
like five ten maybe 15 shows he was
producing shows still got a way to do
his comedy Purdue shows and he left his
gig to do comedy full-time like just
make sure that you're good from a life
perspective that's the best way to say
it for sure and I did what you did and I
uh I set up a nest egg and then jumped
in full time like I yeah I mean I was I
was living lean too I mean Publix BOGO
was my love language and I'm and I am
living in a studio apartment in the
basement of a building in the hood of
Atlanta like you know like I'm I'm
living lean out here saving up money so
I can pursue Comedy full time and saved
up a nest egg
and then I did like a a exercise of like
best case scenario quitting my job full
time worst case scenario am I willing to
live with the best and or the worst case
scenario of this decision and I was and
I jumped in that way but yeah I always
recommend to people like I mean you do
you boo like like we always say here
like at the end of the day you do you we
tell you based on our own professional
experience but like
for me another reason I didn't move to
LA or New York and I built everything
from Atlanta was like my friends that
moved to LA New York you know they're
living in like two bedrooms with four
Dudes like type dealing I was like yeah
they got on late night and stuff and
they're doing great now but it's like
that's I'm not willing to do that for
that essential standard yeah so it's a
small personal preference on that end
so if you want to jump in and like not
really have much the thing when comedy
becomes your job
it's like any other job like you've got
to work on you know you got to figure
out how to get booked you got to figure
out branding and the marketing and all
like it's not like oh you quit and now
comedy's just gonna create you know the
yellow brick road for you nah it's an
it's a constant constant hustle constant
grind every step of the way like I I
just interviewed Steve Byrne 30 years in
the game saying it's still
like it's a constant grind everyone's
trying to figure it out you're just
going from like one thing to the other
just trying to do the best you can so
do it I would say make it
part-time as long as you can until it is
like you can't do your day job or boat
and comedy or comedy is paying as much
as your day job
but once it comes your job it becomes
more of an obligation in a lot of ways
because now you're putting all the
pressure on it to like oh I'm not just
going out here to have bits and hang out
for fun like this is my livelihood so I
really got to figure this out and that
can very easily suck out the fun of it
if you're not careful
yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah and I cranked myself
up said Steve Harvey lived in his car as
well which he did yeah I did a whole I
did a video about it on my drill buyers
YouTube channel if anyone like to go
subscribe to that
because that should have been viral by
now and it has a thousand views so I
don't know what happened there
but that's fine
[Music]
oh but we're reaching the end of our
hour here Yoshi
are we yeah
[Laughter]
I just realized my neighbors are
probably looking at me like what is
this what is y'all doing
I feel like you got chickens back there
you got chickens back there no but I
would if I had more um
if I had if I had more room and like
I definitely would I've got my um
my favorite yard art here
this is a mushroom this is great for the
podcast they're like oh yeah we can see
that
that's actually a hand blown glass
um mushroom from the Tacoma Glass Museum
a father and son
uh made those
and that was like the gift my wife and I
got for each other for our trip to the
Pacific Northwest but once once the once
everything's blooming I'll definitely do
more out here because we got a lot of
hydrangeas and
daffs and mascaris coming up and
oh my God you sound like
I had a line that uh when I did the
Agape church event that you hooked me up
with about my wife is in like a Garden
Club and it's like some and she loves
Antiques and I was like some people
marry some people marry their mothers I
married my grandmother
foreign
that's very funny
what was that nice but yeah
so yeah that was fun oh and ketokero
said organic gardening with Joel buyers
dude I would love to have a gardening
show I would love that
[Laughter]
that's hilarious did somebody have
another question I thought I saw
something just me posted something is
that the one you were looking at
is it normal to go completely blank
after you've done your new stuff on an
open mic even though you have tons of
jokes you could have said yes that is
normal yeah very very normal
that's and that's the thing I think a
lot of young Comics do and I'm I can
still be guilty of that is like going
into like a set especially like an open
mic set and being like well I'm gonna
try six new things I'm gonna do some old
stuff but I'm gonna weave in six it's
like pick your favorite new thing
and just make it your goal of the set to
do that one thing if you get to anything
else that's great that's a cherry on top
but like whenever you try too many
things at once you end up getting none
of them done so not a comedy is such an
incremental set by set by set by set
like build and development so like just
do it one bit one tag one new joke at a
time
fire
Emoji fire
how excited
so let's um
let's land the plane uh
I'm gonna be in um
on March
15th or March 17th and 18th I'm doing
shows in Virginia and South Carolina so
if anyone listening to this has shows
around that area that maybe I could do
this the 16th to the 19th
I'd love to put together a nice run of
shows there
nice
um March that's March yeah that's March
Yeah March 17th and 18th
and then so anywhere around those
regions I would go on either side of
those dates
that um
people are listening
to the podcast
just want to put that out there
crack myself up said Trey's in the
upright position hilarious
but yeah
yeah we'll land the plane but I we
appreciate you all for hanging out
goodness great I can't man when we start
promoting this
won't be a problem game over fam because
the people watching right now are like
oh these are like the OG's they're like
the
other one's gonna be uh shooting with us
in the gym type of vibe you know
oh
I don't know
those are the those are the feelings of
Yoshi so we should put a disclaimer
there
Jody asked the South Carolina I'm in
Abbeville Abbeville South Carolina at
the Abbeville Opera House
I will be performing as white boy Joel
so you guys can come see why boy Joel
at the Opry house that's awesome dude
but it pays right so yeah it'll be fun
all right yeah yeah so it I think we did
it is there anything else you want to
say Yoshi
nah man uh just go work guys uh comedy
is about that work
um incremental changes I I was going to
say uh Jody mentioned something about
just paying for comedy festivals give
yourself a budget and just do like a
couple of Comedy festivals you have to
apply for every single Comedy Festival
I I I thought to myself when I was
looking at festivals hey based on where
I am who are the people that are getting
into this Festival those are the
festivals I applied to then when I saw
people like you know South by Southwest
like uh
um I've seen some big names I'm like I'm
not applying to that I'm nowhere near
like where that is at the point so at
least for me that's where I sort of
gauged right
I saw people how many years they were in
in comedy or you know the kind of stuff
that they were doing so I would say just
incremental improvements is the key for
comedy
um but that's it man yeah I uh got some
stuff coming up in March I'm super
excited about got shows coming got
festivals coming so yeah it's gonna be a
good month man yeah we should get better
about like if we're gonna be out and
about in the out on the road we should
tell peeps because you never know who's
listening that may want to come out or
may one for sure I'm gonna be in
Louisville
um Kentucky
at I think it's laugh Louisville is that
March
uh yeah for World Series on it's between
the 15th and the 18th and my show is on
17th yeah Louisville Kentucky come holla
at yeah boy it's the world series of
Comedy Festival I'm on on Friday if you
guys are out there
very nice well yeah and we do this live
stream every Tuesday answering your
questions
so set your alarms every Tuesday at 5 PM
eastern time we do this live stream on
our YouTube channel and Facebook group
so please come hang out with us live
yay yeah next Tuesday yeah
anything else if you have any questions
I love answering questions
we do this that's yep we do love helping
that's why we do this every week for
free so
hahaha
those are our wives words not ours
that's what we have to read right before
we start the show yeah the pink and
approved by our lives
so true this time I'm giving to you has
been approved by my wife she is okay
with anything and everything that I say
yeah for sure
well all right Hopper at the verse we
will see y'all next Tuesday
thank you